[Musica]
che per i giorni di massima sicurezza è
questa cocaine no il ghiaccio non serve
allora il ghiaccio ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho
fatta per il fatto senza amore non
fatico guarda devi riuscire arrivare col
ghiaccio e cell ha portati bloccato la
festa riprende il volo
gg prego prego vieni altro parente che
come ha fatto senza casa non mi ha
colpito il finale ma adesso stato bravo
è stato tratto probabilmente vai vai le
guardie usciti non siamo usciti quando
ma cos'è sta roba
non torniamo a napoli si imbosca russia
di cuocere la grata aspetta qualche
secondo me dobbiamo fare dei crime in
dono pregio che poi ricorda formare
questa porta qua è finta o vera viper o
no se non si può passare
c'è un passaggio segreto eccolo
attenzione proprio lui che lo trova lì
qua parlami addio sul caduto
bisogna vedere sì però non ho mai
fatturati in bassissimo è una trappola
maledizione lavoro che pensavo e
provarci una porta c'è la portò la e
allora seri steri è in pericolo
eccomi fatto inaspettato ma sicuri si
deve andare di qua no asi qua davanti
paesi aprile ecco labbro f
dall'operazione un unico di che la
maledizione ce l'ho fatta oddio questa
roba da me sei morto se mi aspetti
immagino che io non debba mai toccare il
terreno più o meno prova quindi devo
saltare sulle cose non provo aiutami e
difficilissimo perché non c'è il check
point come faccio spiega mi devo passare
io sono morto lo è solo di noriega mi no
sapevo che c'hanno delle spine
maledizione tutto in modo da trappola
sotto giusto demonio ed è quindi vuol
dire un genio
quindi vorrà rai la rai giorgio e giu
bravo seguiamo il soffitto bianco ok ma
razzista suo livello
iolo madonna che kakà ce l'ho fatto
anch'io vai vai vai aderito l'ultimo non
so se va bene il mio dio
devi andare trovato bacci bravo amico
non credo
cos'è che c'era mette mai capito
trigramma pagata ben 334 e button a sé
nonostante di laporta volevi uccidermi
perso di schifoso maledetto mannaia per
malore cosa invece sia un labirinto sale
buona o finalmente qualcosa di facile
andava dai qui dovrebbe essere
abbastanza fatti vi aspetta ok sono
tornato nella porta di prima madonna che
casino mi sono miliardo di porte sono
tornati all'inizio madonna che casino mi
fate arrivare di la 26 ma stiamo insieme
veramente la ripresa no si va bene
adesso sinistra a destra sembra destra è
l'unica mentalmente per come siamo fare
una cosa buona o poi sempre più colori
109 quella roba lì aspettando rapporto
sede un botto primo lavoro
no non puoi farlo magari si può uscire
da lì da qualche parte non lo so la
torcia non l'avevo vista capirla vai ok
funziona si sono entrato cavolo sono in
un'auto stranissimo vico vieni ok ci si
era an e poi c'è una ma è sicuro che sia
di qua no ammessi perché c'era un
buchino piccolissimo non può non essere
di qua attenzione rigori qua buono buono
ma di questo passaggio in poi ce lo
mangi io no amico c'è una guardia merda
sapere quando vedo secondo vogliamo un
attimo perché no secondo me potremmo
fare a questo punto gli olo jolo
ce l'ho fatta mi colma visto ok
sarebbe stato troppo bello vederti
morire ripresi to let che ho amici cloud
tempo quando ora sta prigione non è una
gigantesca non finisce mai delle
trappole con ied roma prova a cadere qua
perché se no allora potremo andare la
porta con la sua norma che mette poi
troppo ovvia ma cosa c'è un portone
gigante c'è un'uscita strana come fatta
tra la sta roba è ancora in giro ma c'è
un troppe scale mai pero ci sono delle
scale fake riso nel crime cioè non in un
fake proton in più sono tantissime con
l'eccezionale non ero qua c'è un'altra
portale attenzione per mandarli io sono
andato lì all'aria mio sì cosa tira
l'altra volta lo aspetta grandissimo
fatto un salto incredibile
vediamo se mi portavo al che parte e mi
sa che qua e mi sa che devia da esatto è
ora di è quello difficile prova amico io
ho paura e io non sono fatto messa che
la mia era pure chiusa grande e adesso
ecco l'annuncio del fuoco non c'è porta
non c'è niente se cado quando io forse
placido non sono morto ok però punta qua
bravo esatto
ma se dove qua no dove lo metto io prima
di andarci sei sicuro no e prove
scendiamo veniva corrisposta di ok
abbiamo edifici devo che si può fare
aiuto ma no no se mano destra strada
qualora non era acquistiamo dalla
finestra da dire tipo ok sia una piega
della vita tantissimo dai valori ormai
vai vai salita di servizio di santo
stato non so dove stiamo andando quindi
di sempre ci punto c'è poi sarà euro
dice che la funzione ovunque la strada
giusta al checkpoint di c è sì per forza
però amico qua qua ora che questi ma
veramente quasi fuori vedono ci siamo
per niente il zone or ottime guarda vedi
non è fattibile
la ragazza non caschi l'ho toccato
parole di uno toccato ok è una volta che
sei sul legno cosa fai come faccio
saltando grazie amico ci avevi ragione
tu tutte le linee di 40 sia fatta
andiamo ok io non l'ho proprio che ci
sono riguardi il nome ci pensa che i
giri incredibile stiamo facendo dicono
adesso una volta dicono si va avanti un
casino hai fatto per arrivare di come
fatta arriva alla ma totalmente random
perché io ho visto una porta che d'altro
ma ancora questa la porta come faccia a
scendere come faccio a scendere beh ti
butti senza saltare centro saltate hanno
assaltato mi piacevi l'angolo allora vai
dentro che c'è il punto amico dove c'è
poi esaltato il pieno di base a caso ora
ora c'è un terrazzo ora dovremo secondo
me andare
nel terrazzo semplicemente agire alla
guardia possibile c'è un coso occhio al
tipo ma occhio non c'è ma ce la fai
ora devo farmi un chilometro senza spese
sperando che non mi veda non mi vede non
ha visto passare a destra passa adesso
c'è poi qua no alla sentinella scherza
produce un no madonna guarda che mi ha
lanciato un missile mi sono cagato
addosso si bravo non ci hanno sparato
ok issimo adesso bravo una giusta la
tecnica giusta dal vaso ok si si si
arriva ieri a posto ora pronte arriva da
sopra lo sconto sarà qua ci sono che c'è
il check poi ma non si fa guarda vieni
vieni video check point guarda guarda e
ne comprendo io lo prendo per
fedelissimo petta patate qua mi sembra
non è vero lingua no non sei problemi al
vinicola bruciano scappa la sentina e
l'attacca lasciala stare
c'è una scala la prendi la premio amico
dove chi ha sparato ammesse tool a
picchiare fatta amico vero chiudono un
punto di guardia un mio team siamo così
fuori siamo così fuori attenzione buono
buono molto buono buono
ok ragazzi se un quasi usciti non
possiamo fare cose avventate sta
vagliando a gli ha fatto male che li
trasmette la pagina
io lo sono anche partito adesso non è
che partiva di quattro è perfetto
saltiamo oltre la blu il mio dio
oltre questo giro qua senza così piano
così sappiamo ma ovvia fermo gioco lo
guardi ovunque però se lo fai lo devi
fare veloce la parola muro il muro
ucciso vieni corri
ma è una scarpa amico scappa merito che
non si riportano invece fuori siamo
scappati e neovia un piccolo passaggio
un pass aula arrivo arrivo c'è la
trappola ferma non è ancora finito ma
basta de witt ritirarla e non pensavo di
giusti fare al sono mostri sono un
cretino amiche scusami n'attimo problema
che noi i problemi anche per chi non la
vedo ok stregata ce l'ho fatta gli
invece ho fatta trigano bravo va bene
avere c'è un'arma notato una balestra
vista un to kill sicuri che bisogna fare
così
non lo so più mistico e alla sua gente
ammazza gente non le vedono esaurito ma
ci portava le replice portare ma dove
eccolo le scaglie l'altra sete di
vendetta e al mio tre 123 del casinò
mamma mia che sudata bei ragazzi questa
era prison escape con pietro siamo
scappati incredibilmente abbiamo passato
un sacco di problemi ma ce l'abbiamo
fatta
per ora se vi sia piaciuto arriveranno
un sacco di altre come solito iscritti
al canale sono state per iscritti e non
civile
[Musica]